[Musique]
plus de bâtonnier en plastique mais en
papier pour le coton tige en accord avec
la loi biodiversité ces derniers sont
interdits à la vente au 1er janvier les
commerçants en six mois pour écouler
leurs stocks
autres mesures environnementales une
distance minimale de nom d'épandage de
produits phytosanitaires entre 5 et 20
mètres autour des habitations doit être
respectée quant à votre logement
les ménages modestes pourront bénéficier
d'une prime versée par l' agence
nationale de l'habitat pour l'engagement
de travaux de rénovation énergétique
la prime rénove peut couvrir jusqu'à
deux tiers du montant des travaux
c'est la promesse phare des manuels
maquereau ou gilet jaune une baisse de 5
milliards d'euros de l'impôt sur le
revenu ce qui représente 350 euros de
gain annuel moyen pour 12 millions de
foyers et 180 euros pour 5 millions de
foyers déjà lancé en 2019 l'exonération
de la taxe d'habitation se poursuit 80%
des foyers sont concernés en 2020
toujours dans la volonté de diminuer la
consommation de tabac en france
le paquet de cigarettes augmente de 9
euros 10 à 9 euros 20 selon les marques
pour le paquet de 20 cigarettes
objectif pour le gouvernement un paquet
à 10 euros fin 2020 le timbre connaît
lui aussi une augmentation de ses prix
en euros 16 pour le timbre rouge et 97
centimes pour le vert le groupe la poste
explique cette hausse de tarifs pour
compenser la baisse des volumes de
courrier
il fait beaucoup parler en ce moment
avec le projet des réformes des
retraites le statut de cheminot
disparaît pour les nouvelles recrues de
la sncf
il continue cependant à s'appliquer pour
les cent trente et un mille personnes
qui en bénéficient actuellement
enfin une revalorisation du smic de 1 2%
pour les 2 3 millions de bénéficiaires
il est donc désormais de 1219 euros nets
soit 15 euros de plus par mois
il s'agit d'une augmentation légal lié à
une hausse de l'inflation